tout de suite on va présenter l'équipe
c'est maxime cadets benjamins aux
seniors
on est parti dans un supermarché jean
luc qui le fait dans son spectacle
exceptionnel
on dirait pas non mais c'est ça on a
l'impression qu'il a dit à une promotion
des ventes flash dans deux secondes
alors une grosse page anciennes gloires
de la télé en quête de renouveau
il est aujourd'hui une figure appréciée
de tpm b mais pour combien de temps
mesdames messieurs je m'agace elle dit
[Applaudissements]
benjamin taton s'est amené au camp nou
là non plus la chambre m est sérieux
mais toi et mes frères la dre croissance
ça c'est le surpoids fascinant si on
fait on a accompli ces partis vas-y maxi
mairie c'est un peu la nommant de
l'équipe sourire nous ensorcelle et
remonte à pois jusqu'aux aisselles mais
délibéré est attendu pour ce soir j'ai
eu celle de faire quelque chose je le
fais jamais ouais je vais annuler
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc aller a dit michel aussi
lourd qu'une enclume il nous sort assez
fréquemment sa plume il n'est pas encore
sur le banc de touche normal ils
n'hésitent pas à en remettre une couche
jean michel maire c'est le surf et le
pire qu'on ait eu michel away we go non
là c'est pire côté de loin là les mecs
là je vous dire je vous dis non mais
c'est vrai je vous dirai quand vous avez
pas les chats sous l'eau difficile de
soignants corps féminin 1h30 pour les
écrire les bosseurs valeur il brille par
sa valeur excessive sur beaucoup de
points serrés se nomme au bon coeur
bernès est chaud comme la braise aussi
légère qu'une hirondelle
elle adore de compter ses ritournelles
quand il s'agit de déployer ses ailes
elle nous dit qu'elle ne doit retourner
à rtl isabelle morini-bosc m
venez vous oui j'ai rien faire vous dans
vous oui vous avez très bien failli et
de mettre un terme à cette affaire du
maxi bernard séquence en prime il vient
sceller l 2 février un bernard bernard
il brille au soleil comme une gazelle de
leurs et du cips à la vidéo gag
il a aussi présenté le grand bêtisier de
grands verres l'avancé à elle est dans
la place il a fait des animations
mariage sur les possibles à la maison
avec axa - qui comme un poison qui est
une pièce montée qui va arriver ça
devient donc ça commence on ne sait quoi
non mais vous c'est vous êtes comme un
plat dégueulasse on est pour n'importe
comment
agathe fans de réseaux caractère bien
trempé influent ceuzin jour charmeuse
toujours de lui parlait jamais de claude
guette sinon elle va vous faire la fête
à gâteau prouve
[Applaudissements]
excusez-moi supporters c'est quand à la
fin il fait de bonnes affaires le gâteau
proulx ya dominique farrugia qui sera
avec nous d'ailleurs de mon tour de la
table à la fois qui qui me disaient
qu'ils peuvent parler d'un fois il me
parlait de vous et me disais tu vois tu
as fait tout ça pour ça comme je vous
aime beaucoup mon celi qui nous sommes
et c'est presque dommage
jean-luc fin observateur sniper avisé il
loue tambourine avec ses 4 hier mais
rassurez-vous le jour où il passera 16
9ème jean-luc nous visitons enverra au
septième ciel de calage à maxime kenny
donc là je n'avais sans y trompons 30 on
entend un spa possible ya une erreur sur
la cage de chiens ont donc le temps de
chien en âge de chiens c'est l'âge de
110 ans on se met tous l'encouragé pas
et liker dit qu'elle est aussi profonde
de coeur que deux corps
bercy c'est tout pour moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
doté d'une sensibilité à fleur de peau
c'est la bulle d'air de tp mpr dj à
comédienne bientôt elle touche à tout
sauf à moi kelly